a first of its kind app is launching
here in las vegas to change how
fans enjoy live sports the creators of
love seats say the idea came from being
season tick
ticket holders for many teams over the
years
there was hundreds of empty seats every
single game and no way
to do anything about it besides people
sneaking forward which we won't do and
started to you know look at what can be
done about it and
you know with chatting with some of the
teams nothing really existed to be able
to solve our problem
this will launch next month for the
aviators opening game at las vegas
ballpark the app is a way for
fans to buy and sell tickets once
they're already at the event
all right so for example if it's let's
say the fifth inning and you want to
move closer to the field
you can look to see if maybe there's an
available seat
there's a flat fee on sales and pricing
changes in real time as that game
continues to go on
the big benefit is i mean if you don't
like your seats and you want to move you
want you want to
feel more like a vip or you want to be
behind the first base dugout or third
base dugout
it's really about all about maximizing
fan experience so giving the fans
everything they want being able to kind
of sit where they want
even though they maybe don't have the
best seats when the game starts they are
able to upgrade during the game
another use for the app is when you
leave a game early and want to make some
cash on an empty seat
or you want to move to sit with friends
love seeds is also in talks with the
golden knights and a few other
teams across the country